talk about your third point uh what
happens in strip shows and bachelorette
parties couldn't happen in your wildest
rockstar fantasies
okay so back to kind of like the last
store you said you were some 19 out of
the 21 22 girls were
down for whatever um things like that
happen
i remember the first time i went to a
show and there's a guy i've been around
forever
he brought five different girls
backstage
and meet the guys and he'll oil him up
whatever and then he said hey let's have
a titty
city lineup so who's got the best tits
they get a t-shirt
and he said you know what i'll even one
up it whoever shows their [ __ ] has the
best one
can go on stage for free during the show
and you know i thought he's joking well
without hesitation
there you go they're all lining up and
showing that i couldn't believe this was
real life
i couldn't believe people actually did
this and they do this isn't like uh
few and far between this is my regular
thing that happens at these evidence
really wow okay
um what what other stuff did you see him
like
you're talking about rockstar stuff like
wildest rockstar fantasies like what
else did you say
well i mean it was there's never a
question like i've seen guys
you know have lineups of girls outside
their door waiting their turn
i can think of a few times on occasion
where hey
hang on you've seen guys have a lineup
of girls outside of the door
waiting for their turn to be with him
yeah like
i was more i was really picky i was like
the high quality girls right you know i
really wanted just a really one hot girl
for the night
but i had a couple buddies who just
they're breathing they're walking
they're coming home
you know you're a legal in adult let's
do it
and my one buddy
this is a true story i'm not even lying
about this we're in missouri
and it is just a dive of a bar
and um there's just the
most ratchet disgusting women i've ever
seen i mean it's missouri right
no knocking anyone from missouri but
this part of missouri was bad and
um everyone takes off and there's two
vehicles
and one person thought i was with one
guy another other guy so i called the
boys i'm like hey you left me at the
club and they're like well
there's some chicks you're driving home
there's all drunks you're being dicks
i'm the new guy in the crew so i'm kind
of like
you know the bottom of the barrel so i
found
these two girls who seem nice and i said
hey do you want to come party at the
hotel with the boys if you do me right
it's about 20 minute ride
so i brought them all back there's eight
of them and uh
i shove them off to my buddy's room and
my other buddy
he found the sorority girl who invited
all her sorority sisters and
they paid the kid the front desk to open
up the pool so
i will round up all the guys that come
down to the pool party and i go to my
buddy uh we'll say his name
ken believe it can ken and he's in there
he's got seven girls on the bed
one on his bed waiting their turn he's
getting a round out of each of them
well uh there you have it i guess i
guess you're
that's that's basically the definition
of running a train
except it's not a bunch of guys running
a train on one girl it's a bunch of
girls running a train on one dude
i've seen girls go door to door because
we usually get our own room right
they'll go from one door to the next the
next to the next
you know because they got everyone's
number before the show and they don't
tell them that they're at
you know this guy's room from mike's
room or whoever chrome right or donnie's
room they just
hey i'm at the hotel let me see it right
and i watch
door-to-door go home with one guy who
leave with another in the morning
did like like when they were um
when they were going outside of their
relationship these women
and you know having sex with the meal
strippers um like are they
using condoms or are they just like raw
dogging the whole thing
well i don't i don't think condoms are a
common use with some of these guys i
mean
it's just the reality and like they
won't even
ask half the time i mean i had initiated
myself in my case i always had to
bring it up it was very rare someone to
ask if you had one they're just most
people are ready to go
i think it's just kind of living or just
like
if i get pregnant i'll get abortion if i
get an std i'll take a pill
did did any of these girls ever get
pregnant from by any of these strippers
while they were in a marriage or
anything
oh oh absolutely i have worked with some
of the
lowest pieces of [ __ ] when i was down
south uh with a couple of the crews and
there'd be guys that have a wife home in
canada or
up north in the northern states and
hitting up with this girl hit him with
that girl
i've had different girls email me and
ask for this guy's contact because she's
pregnant and
it happens all the time and you know i
um
one case and it unfortunately the girl
did have a miscarriage uh
this girl i know hooked up with my boss
at the time she gets pregnant
he had a fiance of four years
and they had been trying for two years
to get pregnant so she just thought it
was her
so my buddy raw dogs her gets her
pregnant
while her her fiance is off to work for
safety
um my my uh buddy at the time
is definitely um he's a different
ethnicity than her actual fiance
so she's like oh [ __ ] how am i going to
explain this one
okay unfortunately you know she is
scared which you know i mean good for
him but unfortunately because it's never
a positive experience for anyone
and uh he went right back to loving the
guy they're married and
continuing life as as it is now like
nothing ever happened
did any of these women ever pass off the
baby as
you know their husbands or their
boyfriends even though it came from the
stripper
i know for a fact one guy worked with um
he got a girl pregnant he was in a
long-term relationship essentially the
girl took care of all those bells who
lived with her
and the other girl came to the show and
the only reason i know about this is
because she reached out to me to get his
contact which
obviously i said i messaged him and said
yeah i gotta hold this girl i'm not
getting in between this
and she got pregnant she was with a guy
and they agreed
on each other that he messaged don't
tell anyone the kid to this day looks
just like him
wow there are other these guys are
getting other girls pregnant
i mean the reality is this is their
whole train of thought on this
you're with a guy for four or five years
you bang some random stripper who
probably doesn't have apothecin
uh why would you throw that away on the
possibility that you just might not be
that you're just gonna shut up have the
baby you know
yeah i mean you know cuckoldry is a lot
more common than what than what guys
think i mean
um i i'm not that surprised that
um you know these women try to try to
pawn off you know the alpha
seed as the uh you know as a beta's
child but uh
yeah you know there you have it there's
just there's just more confirmation
you